All right, now that we have added some gameplay,
we have added background objects,
adjusted our visual effects,
our lighting, and set up our project to make sure it loads the level we created.
We're now going to take a look at publishing our project for Windows.
But before you do that,
there is a few things that we need to do.
First off, if you haven't done so already,
you'll need to install Visual Studio Community in
order to continue the publishing process.
This is because we need a couple of updated SDKs and
.NETs updates in order to get
the required files to successfully create a Windows executable.
So again, just look for Visual Studio Community in your favorite web browser,
and then download it, install it.
Once you've installed it, make sure you restart your computer,
then launch your Unreal Engine project,
and go up to platforms, Windows, and package project.
Once you've done that, it is going to take a little time,
depending on the size of your project.
It could take a few minutes,
it could take a few hours,
really depends on how much content is going to be packaged.
But once it is done,
you're going to get something like this.
You are going to get a executable,
an RK is going to be boxhunter.exe,
and when somebody launches that,
they're going to be able to play your game from the beginning,
the middle, to the end.
So let's go ahead and pop over to the editor and check this out now.
So again, to publish this, we're going to go up to platforms,
we're going to go to Windows and package.
I'm going to come up to here,
I'm just going to hit delete because I've packages before,
but I have my desktop and then you'll need to make a new folder,
and there's our boxhunter,
so we're just going to say select folder,
and now it's starting to package.
And if we do our show log here,
we're going to see the log of our package.
So we'll be back right in just a few minutes once this is finished.
All right, now our project has finished packaging,
so let's go ahead and take a look at the ending result here.
So we're going to open up my explorer here,
and we're just going to look for our boxhunter.
Going to go to Windows,
and there we go, look, we have our boxhunter, our engine, and our EXE.
So there we go, we're going to double click on that,
and let me just bring this over to this other monitor over here
because it opened up on my secondary monitor.
So let me just bring this over.
There we go, there's our boxhunter, and when I hit start, there we go.
We have our project here,
and I have mine with the default level,
but you should now have the level that you created,
and you should be able to play it just like I'm doing now.
And when we do this, we should be able to go to the main menu,
we can start, or let's just do this one more time,
and we can come here and we can actually quit,
which will end the project.
So with that said,
that is actually going to wrap everything up.
So in today's talk,
we started off with looking at an Unreal Engine 5 recap,
going over the user interface,
viewport navigation, and working with actors.
We then moved on to talking about levels,
we talked about level concepts and how we create levels,
and then we dove into our exercise with our project introduction,
then we set up our levels, we worked with actors,
we added visual effects and background props,
and then finally we published four windows.
So that is all that I have for you in this tutorial series.
I hope you enjoyed watching it as much as I enjoyed presenting to you,
and I will see you next time.